お願いします
特に初期仏教といえば
大変 一番大事な概念の一つとして
考え方の一つとして この ドゥッカ(dukkha) っていう言葉がございます
これについて かなりいろんなところで
この場所でも 何回も同じテーマでお話をしましたし
今 同じテーマでリピートなんですね
で 一番最初に喋った時は 一応まとめて喋りまして
リピートになると それぐらい大体 大雑把で喋りはしますけど
もしかすると4回 5回ぐらいかな
同じテーマで喋りましたと思います
こういうことを 私が考えるようになった理由がありまして
ある 私も勉強途中だからね
いろいろ方々が仏教について語られるときは ちょっと聞いてはみますけど
日本で一番ものすごい人気のある
ものすごい大事というか
有名というかね すごい宗教家として思われている ある方がね
NHK で チラッとこういうことを言ったんですね
釈迦がね 大したことを言ったわけじゃないんだと
釈迦は ただ全ては空だと言っただけでね
もっとすごい教えがあると
と言ったんですけど だから私は考えたのは
この方は お釈迦さんよりも すごいことを知ってるでしょうね
ということを思ったんですけど
その方が言ってることは
やっぱり日本では誰でも大変 信頼してね
信じていらっしゃるし
もう何千人も弟子たちもいて
それから調べてみたんですね
このすごい教えは何なのかと
それで一つ 面白かったのは
世界の平和のために断食する
どこかに隠れて で 面白いことに
それでも 世界平和は成り立ったんです
もう今 世界では どこにも戦争も何もないんです
で 大げさにその方が 1週間か断食しましたからね
それで その問題も解決しましたし
それから 日本の社会の方々に いろんな問題がありまして
病気になったり あるいは死に別れになってね
そこですごく神経がね
ガタガタになって落ち込んだり
悲しかったり 会社倒産して 頭が狂ってしまって
途方に暮れてとかね
そういう方々は 結構そちらに行くんですね
行ったら なんと素晴らしいか
もう直してくれるんです
一つ 般若心経を写経しなさいと
それでみんな 問題解決しているんです
だから大丈夫だと思いますけど
ですから 私が考えたのは
それぐらいのインチキやらね
くだらんことで 迷信といえば迷信なんですけどね
それぐらいのことで 釈迦なんだか 何だ大したことは言ってないんだ
ただ空と言っただけですよと
で 確かにその方はもう 徹底的にこの世の中の喜び
欲 すごく認めてあげるんですね
女の人々がね 旦那が浮気して困ってるので
だから何が悪いんですかと
素晴らしいと あなたもやってください というふうな話なんですけど
名前はもう残念ながらね
言ったら 私は訴えられるかもしれませんから
一応 そこは話に関係ないんです
ただ なんで私はこのドゥッカという言葉について
2 3回喋りました　あくまでもこれ
私個人の主観的な感情で
皆様方は 別にそんな話は 聞きたくはないかもしれません
あまりにもつまらなくて
ドゥッカっていうことが
[dukkha]
パーリ語でdukkhaというんですね
それはごく一般的な言葉で
苦しみという意味ですよ
言葉には それほど複雑な意味があるわけじゃなくて
当時 インドで使っていた どんな単語
どんな言語でも 言語というか分かりませんけど
いろいろ たくさん インドでは言葉を使ってますから
どんな言葉でも 大体 苦しいという 苦しみということに
dukkhaという言葉を使っていたんです
だから 一般的な世界で
みんな これは苦しいんだ
これは大変だとかね これは悲しいんだとかね
そういうことが たまにでも人生にはあります
ですから たまにでも
ちょっとした悲しいこと
苦しいことがあったら
ああ これがdukkhaだよ というふうに言うんですね
その言葉をお釈迦様が使って
偉大なる真理として
語り始めたんですね で
違うところは お釈迦様が これが自分が発見したものだと
私が偉大なる真理を発見しましたと
初めて 人類が初めて発見しました
誰もこんなことを発見していなかったと
それが何でしょうかと
dukkhaであると そう言われると
なんか お釈迦様に笑いたくはなりますね
だってみんな それぐらいdukkhaでしょうと
苦しいでしょうと 大変でしょう というぐらいは知ってるし
dukkhaに何か特別な 何か一言入れてあれば
それは それでもよろしい
そういうことでもなく
単なるdukkhaという言葉で
そんな 何か発見したんでしょうかと
という気持ちにもなります
ですから 後になってくると
お釈迦様がdukkhaだけでいったら笑われちゃいますから
もうちょっと その言葉を伸ばしてみたんですね
[dukkha ariya sacca] ということで伸ばしてみたんですね
ariya っていうのは一般人ではないという意味で
聖者 聖なるということで
で いわゆる優れている
一般レベルを乗り越えている
sacca っていうのは真理
それで ariya sacca といえば
一般的にみんなが言ってる
この人生苦しい 大変という意味と 差がついたんですね
そこで問題はこの
我々が知っているdukkhaと
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているdukkhaって
どんな差でしょうかというぐらいのことで
それほど たくさんのことはしゃべらなくても
できるだけ早く 今日は終了したいとは思っているし
ですから 淡々と早く喋りますが
普通の世の中である
例えばね マラソンを走ってるんだと
半分ぐらい走ったところで 結構きついと
その時も使える言葉というのは
やっぱり苦しいと 苦しかったということは使わなくてはいけないんですね
で そういうふうに日常生活の中で
苦しいっていうことが出てくる
ただ それでお釈迦様がおっしゃった 苦しみという偉大なる真理でしょうかと
そうでないというために
お釈迦様は dukkha ariya sacca という言葉を使っているんですね
何でお釈迦様が苦しみであること
これ偉大なる真理でしょうかと
ということが 経典でこう言ってるんですね
今までこれ知らなかったと
今までこれ知らなかったんだから苦しんでいたんだと
それでこの苦しいということが分かってから
全てのものはdukkhaであると
そういうことを分かった瞬間で
自分の心は 完全な安らぎを体験したんだと
それだけじゃなくて これからも 自分の心には微かにでも 悩み苦しみが生まれないと
もう最終的な平安　自分でもう 平安という境地に入ってしまいましたと
それで やるべきことはやり終えたと
なすべきことは成し終えたと
えーと 育てるべきものは育てて終えたと
これからはやることはなくなったと
すべて終わったと ということでおっしゃってますね
ですから このdukkhaっていうことを知ることが
お釈迦様にとっては 大変な発見でしたし
普通の方々にとっては こんな当たり前の日常のことでね
もっとすごい真理を語ってくれるんだったらね
面白いんだけど なんだそんなくだらんことか というふうに思うかもしれません
だからそこら辺 少々考えてみましょうと
まあ あの
どこから始めればいいか ちょっと
仏教に対する いろいろ批判のところがございまして
特に 大乗仏教に対して学者が何をおっしゃっているか あまりわかりませんし
だから私は 我々の仏教に対して
特に西洋で いろんなたくさんの研究論文が書かれていますからね
そちらの考え方から見ると
あまり仏教に対しては 好意的ではないんですね
仏教自体は悲観的で 気をつけて言うんだけどね
どちらかというと 悲観的であると
世界をね 生きていることを
我々の この世の中を認めていないんだと
暗い教えだよ というふうに
なんとなく言っちゃうんですね
それ他の宗教と比べて言うんですね
ですから 大変 喜びを 楽しみを語っている 他の宗教と比べてみると
仏教は少々悲観的ですと
それで 私は考えたのは
生きること 人生やらね
そういうものは大変 素晴らしいと
と楽観主義で語った哲学はありますかと
宗教がありますかと いろんな宗教がありますね
古い まあね すごく古い宗教からね
現代宗教まで たくさん宗教があります
世の中で　その宗教の世界では
人間について語っています　どんな宗教でも
人間のことを語っています
イランでね 昔あの
なんとかという宗教がありましたね
Zend-Avestā(ゼンド・アヴェスター)という聖書も 今もありますけど
Zoroastrianism (ゾロアスター教) というね
インドになると 今
現代ヒンドゥー教というね
昔は 複雑な宗教がいっぱいありまして
バラモン教とかね ありまして
今は 全部まとめて ヒンドゥー教というんですけど
お釈迦様と もうちょっと先輩で ジャイナ教というものがありまして
インドでね　それで それに比べて西洋の方というか
中東の方にも ユダヤの人々の信仰しているユダヤ教やらね
キリスト教のもう数えられないほど 宗派がたくさんありまして
それからイスラム教という 最近の宗教があります
そちらの中にも いろいろ宗派があります
いろいろあります
だから生きることは すごく素晴らしいことであって
純粋に大変 楽なものだと言っていますかと　誰かが
ですから よく見ると 別におんなじことを言っているんですね
生きることが大変だと という立場で語っているんです
何かしなくちゃいけないんだと
この何かしなくちゃいけないと言っていることが 宗教なんです
キリスト教の方々は我々に あんた方はそんな調子だったらダメですよと
何かしなくちゃいけないんだよ と言っているんですね
イスラム教にしても
そんなことで冗談じゃないと ダメですよと
危険だよと 何かしなくちゃいけないんだと
その何かしなくちゃいけない という部分が宗教なんですね
ですから 修行方法やら お祈り方法やら
何か人がやらなくちゃいけないと言った途端
もうこの世の中のことに ケチをつけてます
別にお釈迦様だけじゃないんです
例えばイスラム教だったら
1日 5回 お祈りしなくちゃいけないんですね
で そういう一つ 1日 5回 神様にお祈りしなさい
神様のことを思って感謝しなさいと言われたら
それだけで 我々の生きている世界を もうケチつけてます
いわゆるお祈りしないならば
それが危険ですからね
何か大変なことになりますから
ですから 世界を悲観的に見たのは お釈迦様だけじゃないんです
全ての宗教で一応 考えてみると
一応 組織的な システム的な宗教であるならばね
そういうふうになっているんですね
それでもお釈迦様によれば
お釈迦様が最初にdukkhaの真理を発見して
それで お釈迦様が最初に 悟りを開いたと
今まで 誰にもできなかったと
というところが 違うところなんですね
だったらdukkhaを いわゆる人生はね
苦しいと 全ての宗教で言ってるんだから
誰でも同じではないかなと
どんな宗教でもね 何か同じではないかな という論理は成り立ちますけどね
いかなるものでもね
dukkhaでしょうと
お釈迦様の違うところは 二分化しなかったんですね
宗教によると この世の中はとんでもない悪の塊で
あの世はそれとは正反対で
善の塊なんですね 二分化していますね
例えば 人間の世界と天国という 2つに分けて考えると
人間の世界は もう苦しみばっかしで
天国に行けば 万事解決だと
それ二分化しているんです
だからこっち危険だから
じゃあ あっち行きましょうと
言葉上ではそういうふうに使わなくてはいけないんだからね
たくさん単語もないんだからね
しょうがないところもありますけど
お釈迦様の違うところは
その二分化がないんです
こっちもあっちもdukkhaだよと
そういう二分化していないところが 違うところなんですね
だから天国に行ったとしても
やっぱり しょうがないんですね
だからお釈迦様は これを言いたがっていたんですね
普通にお釈迦様を知っていた宗教の人々が
天界 天国 何でもいいんですけど
あの世というところにね
そこに行けば安心だよと
そちらに行くための努力をしていたんですね
お釈迦様は まとめて全部dukkhaだよと
二分化できないということで
2つまとめて
1つ白い 1つ黒い とは言えない
一切はdukkhaであると
だから一切皆空という言葉も
ございますでしょう
二分化しなかったんですね
そこをわかったところで 何ですね
発見しましたと もうこれで心の安らぎを得たんだと
というのは そこら辺ですね
この違うところがね 偉大なる真理というのは
あまり 細かく説明してもね
皆様方にそんなことを言わなくてもいいんじゃないかな という気持ちになりますのでね
では 次のポイントで考えましょう
私たちは 生きることは苦しみであると知ってますかと
生きること 苦しい 大変だと知ってますかと
それは 知らないと思います
私たちは 生きることは必ず幸せだと
今 ちょっと文句あっても
そんなものはどうってことはない
確実に幸せになるんだと
幸せそのものだと と一般的には思っているんです
が 違うところは認めてない
だからそこら辺 人間と語りにくいところなんですね
心の中に思っていることとは 反対のことを堂々と言うんですね
だから 本にあるもの みんなが語るもの
みんなの学問的な知識っていうのは
心にある考え方の反対なんですね
だからすごく困っているんですが
普通に言えば 本当はそういうことなんですね
だから人生は大変だと
生きることは苦しいと
ひとかけらも認めたくないんです
絶対的にこれ楽しいとは思っているんです
思って そんなこと言っちゃったら 馬鹿にされるかもしれません
だから なんとか
そうだな やっぱり大変ですよとかは言います
言うんだけど 心の中でそんなことありっこはないんだと
ですから 人々がなんとか悩み事があったら
会社の問題があったら
家庭の問題があったら
で 人間関係で何か問題があったら
いろいろ 偉い知識の方々に言って カウンセリングを受けるでしょうに
で カウンセリングを受けたところで
何言ってくれるかと
というと やっぱり まあまあ
それぐらいのことでね
そんな気にする必要はないんだと
もう大丈夫だと これ ちょっとしたことでしょうと
人生はもう素晴らしく
幸せだと　他の例がないかな
例えば 桃一つ買ってきて
これどうしようか 困った
大変だと 何でしょうか
食べられないんだと なんで食べられないかと
この皮はね ちょっとギザギザみたいな状態で
なんかちょっと毛虫の皮膚みたいな感じでね
なんかちょっと　それで悩むぐらいのことですかね
この桃の皮だからね それは自分の爪ででもむけるでしょうに
あ それ大したことはない
こうやってこの皮を剥いてくださいと
そうすると 美味しい桃が食べられますよと
それが世の中の考え方なんです
世の中の人々がdukkhaだよと言っている苦しみが
パイナップルの皮とは違うんです
パイナップルは 私の国の果物を言ったって意味がないんですけどね
栗のトゲトゲついてますね
栗の皮のようなものじゃないんです
栗っていうのは３つありますね 皮が
一番外に もうとんでもない危険物で
もう触ったら怪我する
それはいくらか自動的に割れますから
もう悩まなくてもいいでしょう
そんなことで すぐ中の種が落ちてきますね
でももう一つ硬い殻がそれでもありますね
それもあの
ちょっと慣れたところで すぐ皮がむけるんです
もう 2枚目 それむいても またまた時々
またあの茶色のもうちょっと 膜がありますからね
それちょっと苦いんですからね
それもちょっとしたことで むくことができます
ですから 栗そのものを見て
ああ 大変だ これ危険だ
触ったら怪我するんだとかね
と思う必要はないんです
皮をむいて もうやり方があるんだと
で それが一般的な人生論なんです
世の中の苦しみについて みんなが語っているのは それぐらいのことなんです
桃に皮がついていても
そんな気にすることがないんです
指でもちょっと爪で 自分の指で全部 皮をむけるんです
リンゴの皮はそれはできませんけどね
だから桃っていうのはすごくいい例えなんです
残念ながら お釈迦様の教えは それと違うんです
それのたとえがないんですね
むいてもむいても 何も得られなくなっちゃいますよと
それは誰かが 玉ねぎの種がすごく美味しいですよ　玉ねぎよりも
言って この玉ねぎの皮をむいてくださいと
そうすると すごく美味しい種がありまして
それ食べてみてください
これこそ 世界でこれほどのごちそうがないんだと
その話に乗せられた人が
玉ねぎの皮を むくわ むくわ
何か最後に 何か見つかるんですかね
皮だけでしょうに 種がないんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている苦しみは 何かそんなものなんですね
我々が表面的に感じる苦しみをなくしてみたら
またもう次に また一つ出てきて
それを剥いてみたら またもう一つ出てきて
結局 苦しみを抜けては 抜けてはと
もう退けて 退けてというか
乗り越えて 乗り越えて
行っても 行っても 次から次へと出会うのは すべてdukkhaですよ
だから 全体的に苦しみだよ というのはお釈迦様の教えで
世の中の考え方は 桃の話で
で そういうことをなぜ言ったかというと
お釈迦様は法句経で こう言うんですね
すべての世の中の 組み立てているもの
できているもの 一切の現象がdukkhaであると知ったならば
それだけのことで 人間は一切の苦しみを乗り越えるんだよと
乗り越えるという それで一切の苦しみについて
この何といいますか
嫌悪感というかね
厭うことになりまして
一切の苦しみを厭うようになりまして
それで清らかな道 聖なる道というか
この真理に出会いますよと
これこそ 悟る道だよと
で dukkhaぐらいは 苦しみぐらいはわかってるんだ
そんな単純なことをわかってるんだと
なんで単純ですか？と思う人々がほとんどなんですけど
悟りを体験した人は 一人もない
だからこの dukkhaという言葉っていうのは
もう大変な お釈迦様から見れば 大変な言葉で
それをわかったら もう悟っているんです
それで別に 何に努力する必要ないんで
もうそれで終わり 終了 卒業
だから じゃあ いくらいろんな哲学で
いろんな師匠で いろんな話があるんだけど
すべてやっぱり dukkhaだ
苦しいですとかね あるんだけど
そういう人々が悟っているんでしょうかと
例えば 仕事に疲れて
本当にもう 生きるってことは大変だなと
なかなか大変だと と言っても
じゃあ悟ってますかね
で 人間の生き方 次に考えてみましょう
人間っていうのは仕事は大変
ものすごくストレス溜まる
胃に穴 もうあっちこっち穴まで開けてしまう
髪の毛はもう どんどん落ちちゃう
大体 実際の年よりは 10年老けている
それで夜も寝られない もう仕事のことで
それで それでもなんとか苦労して頑張っても
思った通りの結果にならない
そういうふうに この全て いいことばっかりかもしれませんけど
それでも人間っていうのは とにかくそれでも努力するんですね
だから努力して
とにかく頑張っちゃう
どんな不幸に出会っても
やっぱりとにかく頑張って
もうチャレンジをして 先へ行くんですね
では考えてみてください
そうやって 乗り越えた人が一人でもいますかと
次から次へと 迷路の中に 壁にぶつかるだけでしょう
人生ということ自体が 一つの迷路のようなもので
一旦 入ってみたら 壁　行き詰まり
じゃあ 右に曲がってまずかったと
じゃあまた戻って また左に曲がってみる
もうまた壁 じゃあまっすぐに行けば
また壁　だから出口ありますかと
人生という迷路の出口が お釈迦様おっしゃっている悟りでありまして
そういう普通の人々は
いくら仕事は いくら苦しくても
私は負けませんと もう頑張ってみるんだと
それで徹底的に頑張る
全然 負けたくはない　どんな苦労しても
とにかく頑張ると 時々
例えば 脳出血やらそういうもの
突然 倒れちゃったらね
もう半身 もう不自由になっちゃうんですね
脳もかなり いかれてしまうんですね
それでも頑張る人々は
ものすごい もう想像できないほど リハビリやって
こちら半分 動かないんだから
言葉なんか喋れません
それでも運動して
リハビリをして
普通の健康な人から見れば
このもう 300倍 ぐらいの労働なんです
運動量なんです 私たちには手を挙げることは何のこともないんだけど
その病気になった人にとっては
ちょっとだけでも手を上げてみること
指を動かしてみることっていうのは
これ想像を絶する 苦しい大変なことなんです
そこまで苦労して 泣きながらでも
とにかく立ち上がると
考えてみれば ありがたい立派な話で
そういうふうに人間っていうのは チャレンジはする
私は聞きたいのは
そうやって脳出血で倒れた人が
3年間 毎日続けて 苦労してリハビリやって 歩けるようになりました
喋られるようになりましたと
じゃあ迷路から脱出したんですか？生きる問題から
その方が 私たちも勇気付けられるぐらい すごい人ですよと
脳出血で倒れたのに
やっぱり もう立ち上がってきましたと
治療も何もないのに いろんなこのリハビリをして
時々 もう癌にしてもね
もうダメですよと言われたら
あなたにダメだと言わせませんよ と言って
しっかりと自分で頑張って
いろんなもう健康方法や治療方法
食事療法とかいろんなことをして
癌が消えちゃったとかね
克服しました というケースはあります
それで問題は じゃあその人は 人生の迷路から脱出してるんですかね
結局 同じことでしょうに
例えば私に 今日は癌がない
それで 1週間経って病院に行ったところで
あんた癌ですよと 悪性でかなり早く成長しているんだよと
その調子で計算してみると
5年ぐらいかなと
それで私が腹が立って
あなたにそんなこと言わせませんよ と言って
いろんな苦労して
もう癌を克服する それは何を得ているんですかね
元の状態に戻ったようなことでしょう
本当は戻ってないんですけどね
癌を克服したからといって
若い時の体調に 健康に戻ったわけじゃないんです
脳出血で倒れた人は もう歩けないと
もう一生そんなものだと言われて
それでは気が済まないんだから
頑張って歩けるようにしましたと
ウォーカーというなんとか器具もなく歩けるんだと
それで何か得ていますかね
だから何でしょうかね
ですから 私たちは不思議なこと
この頑張る人々を応援するんです
それぐらいのことに負けるなよと
私も同じことしてます
なんかくだらんことで悩んでると もう怒るんでね
アホではないかと そんなことでも 来るなよと
もっと大きな問題があったら言ってくださいと
そう言われちゃうと
向こうも腹が立ちますね
自分にとっては大事な
すごい苦しみ 悩みなのに
言われたらもう馬鹿にされちゃったんだと
もう腹が立つのはいいんだけど
それでも立ち上がっちゃうんですね
もう恥ずかしくなっちゃって
やっぱりなんとか自分で解決しますよと
そういうふうに私さえも いろんな生きる上で苦しみが出てきたら
そこはもう もう頑張りなさい
それぐらいのことで負けるなよという一言を言う
それだけじゃなくて 世の中では本当に頑張る人々がいて
そうやっても もう無理だ
ダメだと言われても 自分で頑張って克服する その苦しみを
お釈迦様が聞くのは
それであなたは 何を得ているんですかと
山を登ったような感じで
ものすごい苦労し ひどかったと
もう滑り落ちましたと
ちょっと足が滑って ほんのちょっとのことで
もう死ぬかもしれませんでしたとかね
そこであのロープでも
あのもう何もつけるところもなかったところもありましたと
それでも私は山を登ってみたんだと
だから 登ってから降りたんです
それで得たものなんですかね
だから もう単なる山登りなんです
それぐらい命かけて あなた山を登りましたね
すごいですね と言われても
ですから 別にそれでなんでしょうかね
その世界なんで お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
初めからお釈迦様が すごく違う次元で語っているんです
奥さんと喧嘩するのは苦しみだよということは
お釈迦様に関係ない次元なんです
そこはもう夫婦で何とかしなさいよと
それぐらいのことで あるいはものすごい
もう徹底的なわがままな女性と結婚したんだと
人の話は全く聞かない
もう暴れ馬そのものだと
それでも自分がいろいろ工夫して
克服して 普通のまともな人間に今なっているんだよと
それぐらいのことですから
そんな苦しみをお釈迦様が語っているわけじゃないんです
それは自分で何とかできます
飼っていた牛が 昔の話なんですけどね
自分の田んぼを耕すために飼っていた牛が
檻を破って山に入っちゃったと
田んぼはできない
苦しいでしょうね 食べられる？
食べられない 家族を養えない
子供には食べるものは作れないと
じゃあ山に入って牛を探せばいいでしょう
それで山に入って調べてみると
やっぱり牛は虎にやられているんですね
ああ 大変だ もう終わりと
それでも その人に行く当てがないんでしょうかね
でも何とかすればいいですよ
それでも 何とかすればいい
自分の田んぼはできないんだったら
人の田んぼの仕事をお手伝いでもすれば
それからそれでも何か収入を得られるでしょうに
だから そういう人生の苦しみには
それなりの答えっていうのは
その場 その場であるんです
そんなどうってことはないんです
克服しようとしなかろうが
私はどっちでもいいと
例えば もう足が使えないんだと
使えないんだったら リハビリやって 足を使えるようにするか
あるいはそんな いらん足だからね
切断してしまおうが
どちらでも同じことでしょうに
リハビリして使えるようになったとしても
別にただ歩けるだけの結果で
足を切断して義足使ったとしても同じことで 歩けると
だから何かもう単純で 答えがあるんです
ですから 本当は 人間が思っている人生の苦しみっていうのは
もうあまりにも単純すぎて
それに悩んでいることはすごく面白いんです
子供が言うことを聞かないんだ
もう生きていたって意味がないんだとかね
あるいは 旦那が不倫して家出しました
それで子供一人 もうみんな出て行っちゃったんだと
私の人生 一体何なのかとかね
悩んだりするでしょ あんなものもバカもいいところで
どうってことない そんなことで
それこそ人生不幸だ 苦しいって
そういうことじゃないんですね
いたとしても大したことはないし
旦那と子供が一緒に出て行ったっといても
大したことはないし また戻ってきても
だから何でしょうかねと
そういうことから考えちゃうと
やっぱりお釈迦様がもうちょっと違う次元のことをおっしゃってるはずなんですね
ですから 迷路で考えてみる
迷路というものがありまして
どこへ行っても壁にぶつかる
本当は出口はない
もし全く出口のない迷路だったら
もう 途中で疲れて死ぬでしょ
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
人間の生き方 生命の生き方っていうのは
出口のない迷路の中で
すごく勇気を持って頑張ってはいます
それは別にもう大丈夫でしょうしね
勇気を持って頑張っています
でもみんな出口ないんだからね
途中で死ぬんです それで面白いことに
じゃあ迷路に入ってしまった
周り見たら もうなんか もうここ行ってもなんか壁がある
行ってもなんか壁がある
いいや いいや 私はどこにも行かない
座っているぞと 一人が全然探検しないで座っている
もう一人は そんな怠け者でね
何かしら探しましょうよ と行って必死になって探す
結果として二人とも死ぬ 出口がないんだから
だから どういう評価をすればいいんですかね
何もしないで黙って怠けているよりは 頑張った方がいいんじゃないかな
ということも言えないわけでもないんだけど
だからって何も得てないんだからね
だから逆に考えて その人は疲れて死んじゃったし
この人は何もしないでごろ寝していて死んじゃったし
そうすると何もしなかった人の方が儲かったんじゃないかなと
とも思われるし やっぱり怠けないでとにかくチャレンジしたんだ
探検しましたと 努力しました
すごいというふうにも言えるし
だから人生においても
ただもう怠けてね
何もしないで もうただこそこそなんとかして生きていて
それほど光もなくて そこら辺のサラリーマンで
そこそこの給料で
そこそこ そこら辺にいる誰かと結婚して
そこそこの子供一人二人ぐらい作って
それで年取って死んでしまう
誰も知らない それで子供たちにも聞いたら
あなたのお父さん いつ亡くなったっけねというぐらいのことで
子供たちに忘れられているとかね
そういう人々もいますよ
みんなに悪口を言われるんだから
葬式だけはするんだけど
もうそれから法事なんかはね
忘れている そういうふうな人もいるし
まあ写真貼ったり 銅像を作ったり
国民にスケールで 国民でもう何といいますか
この人が亡くなったことを悩んだり
悲しがったりしてね そういう人々もいる
日本人でもないのに 外国の他のどこかの人なのに
死んだことでこちらで泣く人もいる
すごい人だと そういう人物もいるでしょ
で 死んでもう1500年か
もう1600年 経ってるかもしれませんけど
聞いたら すぐみんな死んだ日にちわかってます
どこで どんな戦いで この人が亡くなったかとかね
自分の父親はいつでしたっけ？とわからないと
ナポレオンだ ナポレオンは何年
何年とか どんな ああいう場所で死にましたよと
というふうな人生も世の中でありますね
ろくに勉強はしない 真面目に仕事もしない
家族のことも もう全然 気にしない
ただご飯食べて ご飯作ってもらったら
それ食べて そのままごろ寝したりとか
そういう 我々から見れば もうだらしない
もうすごい つまらない人生の人も そうではなくて
お金一文もなくても それでも頑張って億万長者になって
日本全国もう会社作るんじゃなくて
世界的に至るところで なんとか株式会社だなんとかとか作って
世界一流の億万長者になって 死ぬ人もいるでしょうし
お釈迦様が聞くのは
その二人とも 何を得て死にますかと
一日ちょっとバイトをして食べている人もいます
それで あの人 誰でしたっけ？
コンピューターの人が ビル・ゲイツがいるんですね
世界一金持ちで どちらの方が立派ですかね
あるいはホームレスの人がいて
ちょっと何か食べるものでもないんでしょうか
そこら辺何かもらって
まあ賞味期限切れた弁当でもいただいて
それを食べて それで寝る
ただ また片側にビル・ゲイツさんがいる
私が聞きたいのは ビル・ゲイツさんにあなたの人生はダメですよと言えますかと
ホームレスの人に
言えないんです
結局 二人とも同じだから
何も得ることなく死んじゃうんです
それ評価次第で
ビル・ゲイツさんが学生の時からも
もうじっとしていられなくて頑張りました
で 会社作って世界一金持ちになりました
大学を卒業してないと
だからすごいんじゃないかと
と評価もできます
逆に何やってるんでしょうね
お金あったって あなたには結局
昼ご飯 2回食べることもできないし
ズボン 4着いっぺんに着ることもできないし
でお金あるんだからって
自分のコートに 1ミリ単位でダイヤいっぱいつけて着ることもできないしね
気持ち悪いでしょうに
そんなことしても
別に誰も面白がらないしね
そこで彼が 世界で一番高い美術品やらね
もうボンボン買ってるんだと言っても
どこかの美術館みたいなものを そこで置いているだけでしょうに
だから ある美術館にあった美術品が この美術館に引っ越しただけのことで
その引っ越しのために 4億円かかりましたと
距離としては もしかすると40キロぐらい距離とかね
実はそういうことでしょう
彼もいろんなものを集めていますけどね
すごい高価な美術品とか競りに出しちゃいますね
ある屋敷にある品物を競りに出して
これは 4億円ですよ
はい 買ったぞという その人はそれを持って自分の部屋に
この部屋からあの部屋に移動する
二人とも死ぬんですね
結局 あの品物を置いておいて
だから そんなバカバカらしいことを何もしないで
あの道路の階段の下にしゃがみ込んでいる人は
なんかお腹がすいた そこら辺ちょっと 何かもらいましょうと言って食べてきて
またしゃがんで こうやってごろ寝していると
だから本当は 評価は難しいんです
あなた ただ座っているだけで
私はこの美術品 こちらからここまで引っ越しましたよと
どうやって威張れるんですかね
どれぐらい？これはもうかなりきつかったと
競争も激しかった もうやっぱり4億円も値札は付いてんだよと
その4億円 値札を払うために
その人どれぐらい苦労しますかね
そこでホームレスの人から あなた もともとあの絵をね
運ばなかった方がよかったでしょ
楽で 絵の引っ越しにそれぐらいお金かかるんだったらね
名義変更に そういうことで
この世の中では みんな人生は努力するべき
努力するべきです 言うんだけど
答えなんですかね やっぱり空しいでしょ
よくよく見ると　何か無意味なんですね
美術品は引っ越しする
例えば アメリカにある誰かの絵とかね
日本で人気ある画家っていうのは 何人か決まってますね
まあ ゴッホやらね ヴァンなんとかって
なんでしたっけ で そういう何人かがいてね
その人のこれぐらいの絵をね
アメリカから飛行機で日本まで運ぶと
まあ5億円だと 別に運ばなきゃいいでしょうし
それで5億円払うということには
もうかなり苦労しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そういう人生なんですね
ですから dukkhaっていうのは
本当は苦しいっていう意味じゃなくて
空しいという意味なんです
そこが お釈迦様の違うところなんです
私たちは空しいと思ってないんです
有意義だと で よくよく考えちゃうと
何やっているんでしょうかと あなたは
と聞きたくなります
あのフンゴロガシって虫がいるんですね
生まれた時から一生懸命苦労して
もうフンをね 大体この動物のフンですけどね
あの牛やら馬やらね それを集めて集めて
丸めて それで もう死んじゃうんですね
とにかく終わってから
で フンゴロガシに聞いたらね
あなたは生まれてきて 何をなさいましたかと
これからあなたのあれ
何て言いますか 歴史書きますからと
本を出版しますからと
私は大きなフンをね
フンの玉を作りましたと
そこで同じ人が 人間にインタビューしても 同じことですよね
私は あの会社を私が作ったんだと
今は90歳だから もう引退
別にそれ 仕事もないでしょう
だから同じことなんですね
あのモハメド・アリに あなたは人生で何を得たんだい？
私はもう ボクシングチャンピオンで 世界チャンピオンで
これぐらいトロフィーを持っているんだと
はい わかりました　じゃあ こちらサインしてくださいと
サインできません もう手足動かないんです
病気ですからね
だからわからない　モハメド・アリさんが
ワールドチャンピオンになったこと 悪いかと
悪いとは言いにくいし
頑張ったし だからといって
その人は何を得ているんでしょうかというと
人生というものに対しては何も得ていないんです
今は激しい あのあれ あのパーキンソンという病気でね
手も足も動かなくて
こうやって震えながら 歩けないし
車椅子で あの 前の大統領
誰でしたっけ？あの ん？今 病気になっている人
レーガン
このレーガンさんにしてもね
堂々と光り輝いて 大統領としていて
今 おそらく自分の名前はわからないという状態になって 亡くなる
だから亡くなる瞬間で
レーガンさんに 大統領でいたこと
世界で一番強い政治家に リーダーになったことは
どんなふうにプラスになりますかね
遺体の周りに 偉い人々は集まるでしょうね
亡くなったら　それぐらいでしょう　それ別に
ですから このちょっと残酷に 人生を見なくちゃいけないんです
きつく　見てみると どっちでも同じだと
だから私は言いたいのは
ミミズいますね だからミミズが土の中に入って
もう動いて動いて
ちょっと外 穴を掘って
それから腐りかけてる葉っぱ一つ 引っ張ってもらって
それを食べて またちょっと先に進んで
また一つ食べて先に進んでとか
そこで 途中で亡くなっちゃうでしょうに
それと偉大なる人 名前を言うのは失礼になりますから避けますけど
そうやって世界征服しました というふうな偉大なる人の人生って
どこらへん 何が違いますかね
何か形跡 残しちゃうんですけど
ミミズも 素晴らしい形跡を残して亡くなるでしょう
土の中であっちこっち穴を掘って
それで葉っぱ食べては 出す
食べては 出すと それで土が生きているんですね
それで植物はものすごい立派に
それぐらいのことを 偉大な人間にできますかね
世界征服している人々にできますかね
よく考えると ミミズぐらいの仕事もできないんじゃないですかね
ですから この人生に
人生楽しいか苦しいかという問題じゃないんです
人生そのものが どう頑張っても
どう努力しても どう踏ん張っても
やがてはい バイバイ さようならと
ご褒美なしに終わっちゃうんです
あなただけ特別だよっていうこと
誰にもないんです その意味なんですね
dukkhaというのは
だからお腹が痛くて苦しいとかね そんなもんじゃないんです
地震で家が潰れちゃったんだから
もうすごい悲しいんだと
なぜそういうものは苦しみではないと言えますかというと
地震が起きて 家が潰れて
人生は苦しいわけじゃなくて
その被害者だけ苦しいんであって
それは全宇宙的な真理ではないでしょう
洪水で流されて死んで
やっぱり苦しい そんなことお釈迦様はおっしゃりません
なぜならば 洪水で家を流されて 人が死ぬということは
これ稀なケースでしょうに
みんなにあることではないでしょう
地震は起きるわ
火山が噴火して 村や町が丸ごと 灰で
つぶされるわ っていうのはどうってことない そんなことは
どこでもみんなに起こる出来事じゃないんだから
例えば人間 なんとか もう がんになりましたとかね
事故を起こして 子供でも親でも誰でも 死んでしまったとかね
そういうのは 全ての人類にある問題じゃないしね
誰かが たまたまそういう不幸に出会うだけで
仕事をクビになることも
仕事がちょっときつくなることも
会社でちょっといじめられているんだ っていうぐらいのことっていうのは
これはもう
万人の真理 人類の真理というわけじゃないんです
ちょっと何かすれば それは解決できます
ですから 私たちが考えている苦しみは お釈迦様にとっては全然 考えてもないんです
ですから 私たち考えた人生は幸せだということも
そのレベルなんです 赤ちゃんが笑っちゃったとか
それですごい幸せ感じるでしょ
そんなレベルなんです
奥さんと例えば もう 1年ずっと喧嘩ばっかりしていたんだと
そこで 自分がそこら辺で安売り売っているところで
まあ６万ぐらいの指輪を買ってきて
普通の値段だったら もしかすると 1万5000円ぐらいかもしれません
指輪買ってきて もう喧嘩ばっかりだから
あなたにプレゼント買ってきますよと いうのも恥ずかしいし
言えないし そこら辺にちょっと置いて帰ると
奥さんがそれを見て もうなんかすごく喜ぶ
喜ぶんで一言で言ったら
やっぱり あなたっていうのは本当にいい人ですねとか
一言 言われたら
それだけで あの男の人の 今まであった
苦しみも全部 消えちゃって　まあ幸福なこと
そこら辺に私のような仏教を語る人がいたら 殺されるかもしれない
お前らダメだと こんなに人生幸せなのに
ですから人間語っている幸せも 大体そんな程度のものなんです
親に逆らって 親に迷惑は一生かけて わがまま放題で
もう大きくなった子供でも
いくらか一人前になってきてくるところで
あのわがままなくなっちゃいますからね
やっぱり世界一で お母さんお父さんというのは やっぱり世界一ですねと
一言だけ言っておけば
それで一生 大丈夫です
あの両親は一生 自分の子供というのは最高だと思ってくれるんです
それから別に 面倒を見てあげなくても 何でもいいんです
それぐらい単純でしょ
皆さんはそうでしょう 結局は
それぐらい一言 言ってくれればね
だから 人間が思っている幸せも 大したことはない
人間がいう苦しみも 大したことはない
逆に考えてみてください
奥さんが旦那をよく褒めるんだと
ちょっとしたことでも なんとかいっても
例えば だからあなたと結婚したんだよと
言われると 旦那さんはすごくなんか 踏ん張っちゃって
褒めてくれたんだからね
今日はちょっとボーナスがね
去年よりはちょっと 2万円多いですよと言ったら
だから私はあなたと結婚したんだから
というと なんかすごく 別に何も理屈ないんだけどね
それで 男としてはすごく喜んじゃうんですね
自分を認めてくれたんだから
褒めてくれたんだから
それで考えてみてください
25年間そうやって 旦那さんは褒められっぱなしで
大げさな褒めではなくて
ほんのちょっとの褒めなんですけど
そこで奥さん 2人がおばあさんになったところでしゃべっていると
あなたよく旦那さん あいつはバカだからね
おばさん二人で せんべい食べながら喋っていることだからね
であなたはね なんかうちは旦那とよく喧嘩するんだけど
あなたはやっぱり変わって喧嘩もないしね
よく褒めるもんですねとかね
うちのやつはね バカだから
それ一言 言ったとします
それで自分の耳に入ったとします
あの 40年間の褒めは どうなるんでしょう その場合は
40年間のあの舞い上がり　あの自信
それぐらいもろい幸せなんです
苦しみも同じくね ものすごい
もろいものなんです　大したことじゃないんです
人が病気になっただけで
ものすごく もう真剣になって 泣いたりわめいたりする
もし その人が死んじゃったりするでしょう
もう納得できなくて 我慢できなくて
まあ１ヶ月か３ヶ月間ぐらい経つと
もうじりじりと忘れてしまうでしょう
まあ そこがお釈迦様が
だからあんまり そこは喋ってないんで
ほんと言ってますよ こんなつまらないんだと
あなた方の幸せなんかは 何なのかと
あなた方の言ってる不幸も 何なのか
そんなぐらいのことって
なんかちょっとした シャボン玉のようなものでしょうと
あ 綺麗と思った瞬間 もう弾けているんだから
それで人生という そのもの
いわゆる人生ではなくて
生きているということ
だからミミズにしても
生まれて死ぬまで生きているんだから
そのセットを全部 考えてみると
すべての生命を考えてみると そんなもんですかと
だから自分の人生に点数を入れてみると
正直に　プラスもマイナスもあって
全部 総合計算してみると0になっちゃうんですから
だから人生ね 幸福もあって不幸もあったり
だからプラス入れて マイナス入れて
プラス入れて マイナス入れて
全部 私の人生の総合点数は あら ゼロですと
そこが 誰が点数入れても 同じことなんです
本当は0っていうのは すごいことなんです
なかなか0にならないんです
ほとんどマイナスなんですけどね
これ まれな珍しい人がね
人生を計算してみると 0になりましたと
といえば それがすごいことですけど
でも皆様方 0ですということにも 笑っちゃったんだからね
本当は0になるのも もう
何千万人に一人ぐらいの人間なんです
大体 我々は1年間苦労して 1時間楽しむというぐらいの割り当てなんです
だからマイナスで それはどうでもいいんですけど
やっぱり結局 すべての生命って そういうことだと
宗教の世界では それは多かれ少なかれ
もしかすると そんなものではないか という気持ちもあるんです 人生は
だから天国に行こうではないかと
JRのコマーシャルがありますね　京都へ行こうと
そんな風なコマーシャルを出すんですね
だから天国に行こうではないかと
天国に行ったらこういう人生でない ということは どうやってわかるんですかね
そういうことで お釈迦様は
生きているという そのものが何なのかと 研究してみたんですね
それでお釈迦様はまた 普遍的な定義を見つけて
その定義は 神々にも誰にでも当てはまる
で 天国の話を聞いてみてください
別に どんな宗教の話でもいいんです
天国の話 阿弥陀様の極楽堂の話
皆様方 天国のこと知らないんだったらね
同じ似てる話でしょ
その話を聞いてみてください
そちらにいる人々も 結局 我々と同じでしょう
例えば 天国に行ったら 何一つも見えませんよと言ってみてください
書いてみてください 誰も行きたがらないでしょうに
天国に行ったら かすかな音でも聞こえませんと
これから皆様方に 天国のお話をしてあげます
この天国ということは大変 素晴らしいところで
まるっきり 何一つも見えません
そちらはまるっきり 何一つも聞こえません
その世界でまるっきり 何一つも味わうこともできませんと
その天国でまるっきり 何も感じることもできませんと言ったら
誰が行きたいんですかね
誰も行きたがらないんです
だから天国のストーリーを書く方々は
天国では見たい放題 美しいものを見えると
遊びたい放題遊べると
耳には ものすごい美しい音楽しか触れませんと
口には 最高のおいしい味しか触れません ということしか書いてないんです
そういうのは 神話物語なんですが
実際にお釈迦様は 天界と超次元のね
生命と話し合ったり
見ていくことがよくありましたからね
みんなくだらなくて 同じなんです
低次元の神々と喋った
こういう質問された こういうふうに答えたとかありますよ
大したことないんです
人間よりはちょっと鋭いことを聞いたりはするんだけど
それでも お釈迦様から見れば そんな程度ですかと
あるお坊さんが すごい若い人なんです
昔 今じゃない お釈迦様の時代で
すごいもう ピンピン元気な若い人でね
森の中で 一人でずっと瞑想してるんですね
そのお坊さんのことを何か気に入った 神がいたんです
まあ神霊ですけどね 心配するんですね
こんな元気な若い子がね
かわいそうに 森の中で 一人で修行ばっかりして
心配しちゃったんです
心配して この若者に見えるように来たんです
来て 君がね 目の前にいっぱい楽しみがあるのに 人生はね
なんで遠い将来の幸福のために頑張るんですかと
修行することはいくらか分かってるんで
修行するということは
もう遠い遠い将来 やがてなんとかいいことあるでしょという将来的な計画なんですね
でも こんなかわいくて
すごい元気な美男で 若くて
こんな男の子がね 森の中で一人で頑張るよりは
目の前の楽しみを味わった方がいいんじゃないかと
みんなとも遊んだりね
もう若い女の子でも見つけて結婚したりとかね
だから目の前の幸せをね 置いておいて
遠い未来の幸福を目指して
あなたね なんか悲しい　かわいそうと
言ったら この若いお坊さんは
なんか こいつは言ってること なんかおかしいんじゃないかと思って
この人なんかおかしいこと
あまり勉強してないんですよ 仏教は
修行するんだけど
ちょっと待ってください
お釈迦様の教えから見れば
私たちは 目の前の幸福を捨てて
将来の楽しみを得るために頑張っているわけじゃないんだと
お釈迦様の話から見ると
我々こそ 目の前で幸せをつかもうとしているんじゃないかなと思いますよと
言っても　それはあなたどういう意味ですかと
どういう意味ですかと聞いても
私はわかりませんと だと思いますよと
困ったんですね 向こうの人とこの神霊が
それで若者も
それあなた説明してくださいと言われたら
若者は私にはできません
一応なんかそんな感じの話をお釈迦様がしているんだと
遠い将来で幸せになるために今は苦労しているのではないんだと
君たちが　君たちが今すぐ
今の瞬間で幸せになるために 修行しているんだと
仏教は今すぐ 結果を得られる教えだよと
明日ではないんだと という話は聞いたことがあるんだと
意味はわかりません
だから神霊に言ったんですね
あなたね 自分で聞いてみたらどうですかね
私の邪魔をしないで 私はお釈迦様に会えないんだと
もう修行中だから あなたは行ってきなさいと
言ったら 神霊はこうお願いするんですね
と言っても 我々は霊の世界でね
お釈迦様に近寄れないんだと
そちらはものすごい巨大なパワー
力のある神々やら霊 神霊たちやらを集めているんだから
我々はものすごく遠くて 近寄れないんだと
でもあなた方は同じ人間でしょ？だからもう羨ましくてたまらないんですよ
だから自分にはお釈迦様に聞こえるんだと
だから聞いてくださいと
あなたがその質問をすると
私もあなたと一緒に行って
説法聞きます 聞きますよと言って
はい わかりましたと そのお坊さんが修行
その時期終わったら お釈迦様に挨拶して
お釈迦様に こういうほんのちょっとおかしいことがあったんだけど
村の中で私は一人ですけどね
なんか変な姿の形の人が来て
私をからかったんだと
私も からかいは返せはしましたけどね
でも結局 説明できなかったんだと
それでその神が お釈迦様に説明を聞いてくださいと頼んだんですけど
結局 私もわからないんだからね
お釈迦様 できれば説明してくださいと
もしかすると その変な霊も そこら辺に今いると思いますよと
言ったら その霊もやっぱりいたんで
いて その後ろにいて 耳に言ったんで
もう聞きなさいよ 比丘よ
お釈迦様に聞きなさい 私が聞いているんだからと
言ったら お釈迦様は その若者は問題はないんだから
この神霊にやっぱり答えたんですね
でもその答えはすごい
4行の経典で すごく難しいんですよ
もう私にしても 二 三時間かかります
解説 解釈する 説明するために
いわゆるこのインファリブル (infallible)
この言葉で表れない世界について
いわゆる表現しにくい
表現に成り立たない世界についてという話でね
言ったら その神が全然わかりませんと
言ったら またお釈迦様は 他の偈を教えたんですね
でも 難しすぎてわかりませんと
それで またもっと柔らかいこと
それでもわからないんですね
最後に もうしょうがないということで
お釈迦様はね やっぱり生きている間はね
悪いことをやめなさい
生きている間は 悪いことをやめなさい
いいことをしなさい 心を汚すなよと
はい 終わりと それぐらいだったらわかりますよと
その神霊が喜んで帰りましたけど
中国の話もありますね
ある中国のお坊さんにね
ある偉い人が会って
あなた方の仏教は何をおっしゃっているんですか？と言ったら
この悪いことをするなかれ
善いことをしなさい 心を育てなさい
それが私たちの教えだと言ったら
その偉い人が なんだ ガキにも言えることではないかと
そしたらそのお坊さんが
それはその通りです
でも 世の中で一番頭のいい知識人でも 実践はできないんだと
と言い返しましたそうで
それは中国の話でね
お釈迦様も悪いことをするなかれというだけでね
単純だ 単純だと思ったらね
それはちょっと違うし
その話も 言ったのは やっぱりこの 人間が思っている幸せっていうのはね
それほど大したことじゃない
とにかく神々の話から入りましたから
神々の世界にしたって
我々知っている 我々の伝説
物語にある神々っていうのは
人間とほとんど同じで
お釈迦様に出会った神々にしても
それほど大したものではないんですね
他の宗教で出てくる神々よりは
立派に頭は動くんですけどね
立派なことを考えたりはしたんだけど
やっぱりそれでも それほど生命としては生命であって
ですから 結局は生きていて
年取って亡くなりました
ご苦労様です それしか言えないんです
誰の人生についても ミミズの人生についても
フンコロガシの人生についても
ゾウさんの人生についても
世界のすべて 素晴らしい人間の人生についても
天界の神々の人生についても ご苦労様でしたと
その価値 その意味がお釈迦様は 生は dukkha であると
生きることは dukkhaであるとおっしゃったので
空しいという意味なんです
それ微かにでも知っておけば
すごく楽になるんです
ただ 日常生活の中 いろいろ問題あるでしょう
大体 人間というのは それだけに精一杯 命までかけるでしょうに
そこまでかける必要あります？単純 単純で
学校の問題であるか 教育の問題であろうか
政治的な 経済的な問題であるか
夫婦の間の問題であろうか
もうあまりにも単純で
そんな命かける必要はないんでしょうに
なんでこれ一生 命かけるかというと
人生 空しいと思ってないからなんですね
どうせ最後は空しいんだからと わかってしまえば もう楽なんです
なんで私だけ不幸ですよと
例えばガンだよと言われるでしょう
そうするとなんで私に？といきなり聞くでしょうに
あれが 不幸中不幸なんです
ガンにかかってもかからなくても 同じですから 結局は
どうせ 何も得るものなく死んでしまうんです
手ぶらで　そんなにヒステリーになって
神経質になって 苦しむ必要はないのです
だから人生は全部 そういう
もうということだとわかったら
会社に行ったところで
会社の社長でも係長でもいいんですけど
自分を呼んで あなた明日から仕事に来なくてもよろしいですよと
一応３ヶ月とか あるいは１年分ぐらいの給料は 後で会社で振り込みますからと
3ヶ月とか言われたら
それだけで自殺したくなるでしょうね
でも 人生は神々であろうが
全部まとめて どう見たって
迷路の中で ぐるぐるやっていることだから
ああそう はい わかりました
それで終わっちゃうんです
じゃあ早くお金を送ってねと
明日から 他のことをやればいいでしょうし
だから あまりにも楽になるんです 生きることは
あまりにも楽になるんです
何があっても この世の中でみんな神経質で
もうお互いに競争して戦って
牙を出して もう負けてたまりません
たまりませんとかね もうやり合ったりしていて
ではすべて どう見ても こんな意味だよとわかっている人は
こうやって もう足を手を組んで 見ているんです
これは並の楽しみじゃないんです
その楽ということが だから苦を知りなさいと
dukkhaを知りなさいと
それからもう一つ dukkhaがありまして
この私たちにとっては
もう本当は認めてなくないんだけど
すごい苦しみ ストレスがあるんです
誰にでも 生きてるんだったら
それは何でしょうかというと
私たちは 生きることには価値を入れてますね
命は尊い 当たり前と思ってるでしょう
この尊い命 その一言が 生きるものとしては悪魔の言葉なんです
仏教ははっきりと 悪魔の言葉だと言っているんです
悪魔の言葉 悪魔は来て
このように語りました
人間にとっては この世の中で生きることこそ 幸せな尊いことはなしと
それで それについて 聖者はこういうふうに答えたと
この世において 執着して生きることほど 苦しみがありませんと
ですから あれが悪魔の言葉なんです
人生は尊いと 生きることは尊い 命が尊いと
なぜかというと
尊いんだから 自分にすごい価値を入れる
ですから 手段選ばず 生きていなくちゃいけない
喧嘩してでも 生きていなくちゃいけない
相手を殺してでも 自分が生き延びなくてはいけないんですね
それはどれぐらい苦しいと思いますかね
だから不幸になったら
なんで私が不幸になったんですかと
月一回 100円神社にお賽銭しているのにとかね
だから いくらもう 1万回 経典をあげても
何をしても もう そういう不幸になったら
みんな なんで私がこうならなくてはいけないんですかと
なんで 私がやることは失敗するんですか？とかね
とすごい苦しみを感じちゃうんですね
だからその ごく普通な成功であろうが
もう成功でなかろうが
ものすごくストレスを感じ
例えば すごく成功している人がいますね
会社　ものすごい抜群に もう億万長者になってるんだと
すべてうまくいって そういう人にしても
やっぱり頑張らなくちゃ
新しいものを アイデアを作ってチャレンジしなくちゃ
これが潰れたらいけないと
ここまで成長させたんだから ということでしょうに
お母さんも 私にはもうご飯も
食べさせることはできなくて
苦労してバイトばっかりして
夜 私は一人で 悲しく寝ていたんだよと
お母さんが仕事に行って
それでそういう私が 今 日本で一流のランクの金持ちになっていて
お母さんもすごいと今 喜んで楽しがっているんだよと
だからこの会社が この仕事 この商売
ずっと回らなくちゃあかんと 苦しんでるんです
その人には 寝る暇も休みも何もなく
頑張らなくちゃいけないし
だから価値を入れると
そちらにすごい苦しみが出てくる
そこで祈り 尊い と思ったとしても
面白いことに みんな死ぬんです
そこで みんな確実に死ぬにも関わらず
よくあんなことを言うんです
尊いと
もし死ぬこと 死ぬものが尊いんだったら
もうカボチャも尊いし
落ち葉も尊いし もう何でも尊いでしょう
そこで自分に 命に価値入れちゃうと
死にたくはない という気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
それだけは嫌ですと こんな尊い命
死にたくはないと思った途端
また限りなく苦しみ ストレスがかかってくるんです
死にたくはなくても 死にたくても
どうでもいいことで死ぬんですから
放っておきなさいというのは 私たちの考え方なんですね
それよりはもう必ず死にますと
それは確認しておく 必ず消えますから
そこら辺で そこそこ生きてましょう ということになるでしょう
そんなに感情的に 嫉妬
憎しみ 苦しみ 競争心
なんで苦労するんですかね
生きている日にちは決まってるでしょうに
何日間あなたが生きているんですかと
だったら その決まってる日にちで人と仲良くして
楽しく気楽にいればいいでしょうに
死なないだろうということを仮定するんだから
1年間苦労しても  1年間喧嘩してもへっちゃらですよ みんな
時々 40年間も恨み憎しみを持ち続ける
時々 60年間  80年間でも 恨み憎しみを持ち続ける方々もいますでしょう
だから ああいう人生はもう 空しいと言えるところじゃないんですね
空しいの上で 苦しみの塊なんです
ですから この価値入れる
人生に価値入れる 大事だと思う
それこそが 悪魔の言葉になってしまって
人間には いかなる苦しみも作ってくれるんです
ですから 価値がないんだということで dukkha と言うんです
価値がないんだということは ごまかしではないんです
本当は価値がある
でも ちょっと我々騙されて 騙して
お釈迦様が私たちを騙して価値がないと言っているということでもないんです
我々は子供騙しするでしょ 嘘を言って
子供に落ち着いてもらうために
そういうふうにお釈迦様は 子供騙し言ってるものじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様は堂々と言うんだ
自分が徹底的に研究したところで
修行してみたところで
あ 全ては無意味で 価値がないんだよと発見しましたと
それで もう悟っちゃうんです
あ なるほどと
それで全部 「サル」が　サル ありますね
で サルはこの　ザルと言うんですか？入れ物
ザル ザルありますね それはいくら大きくても
大きければ大きいほど
例えば 川の中に入れておいてください
かなりの水はその中に入ってます
でも上に上がったら何一つもないんですね
軽々と そういうふうなことで
あ なるほど そんなものでしたと
本当は 我々も バカでかい人生というザルを持っていて
それは川の中にあるんですけど
これは運べそうもないんだ
こんな水 重くて重くて冗談じゃないかと悩んでるだけで
もう取ってみてくださいと
何のこともない サラサラと水が落ちちゃって軽いと
だからこの人生 生きるということは穴だらけだとわかった瞬間で
あの煩悩というものは 全部 お釈迦様の心から落ちてしまったんですね
だから私たちは 余計な価値を入れているんだから
それも非論理的で よくよく見ると それほど価値あるというわけじゃないんですね
で 大変苦しんでいます
ですから お釈迦様が苦しみをなくすために 苦しみだよと言っているんです
苦しみも余計なことで
私たちのすべての苦しみは
愛別する苦であろうか
病気で苦しむことであろうか
年取って苦しいということでも
もうどうってことはないものなんですけど
でもそこに我々は足引っ張られて
手を引っ張られ 足かせ手かせでもう動けなくなっちゃって
もう嘆きわめいていますね
だから苦しみの上で苦しむ
気楽に空気のように動けなくなっちゃう
そこは一つのもう一つの dukkhaの意味なんですね
また意味があります
とにかく 我々の注釈書で dukkhaっていうのは
この苦しいと訳してないんです
du という分析するんですね
こういう風に du ということと kha ということ
[du-kha]
で du の意味は その場合によって意味が変わりますけど
その場合はいわゆる無価値
大したことはないという
ことを言うためにこれ付けちゃいますと
日本で言えば なんて言いますかね
日本語で何か似ている言葉
ん？
日本語もあると思います
思い浮かびません 例えばこのまあ小屋という言葉がありますね
「小」屋と言ったとたん 豪邸ではないんですね
小さいという漢字を入れただけで
一つの漢字（屋）の前に 「小」という字を入れちゃうと 小屋と読んじゃうし
それで意味も同じでしょうに
どうしたことはないと
例えば 石と書いても なんかちょっとわからないんです どんな程度の石かと
それに小石と入れちゃうと
あるいは 石ころにしちゃうと
「小」は 頭に入れるか
最後に 平仮名でころと入れるか
どちらかでしょう 石ころといえば 誰も気にしないでしょう
でも石だけだったら ちょっとわからないんですね どんな程度ものかと
川の前に「小」入れたらどうなりますか？小川でしょ
そうすると別に小川 そういう感じで
そんな大したことない という意味なんです
別に 小という漢字書いても
それは小さいという意味ではないんです
漢字にもいろいろ意味がありますからね
だからその場合に意味が
小さいという意味でも使います
小屋って言えば 小さいという意味でも使いますが
やっぱり価値としても 別にそれほど豪邸ではないという意味でもあります
そういう風に 名詞の前にほんのちょっと一言 付けるだけで
あるいは名詞の後ろに ほんのちょっと付けるだけ
意味はない まあそんなもん
そんな大事に考えるものではないんだよと
ですから そこはそうやって
この 無価値 非価値という意味で du 使います
kha っていうのは 空に kha というでしょうと
空という意味なんです
空はどういう風に言いますか？空でしょ
ですから 意味もないだけではなくて
それさらに大したことはないと
それで dukkha ですよと
いわゆる空しいということなんです
単純な日本語で言えば
kha は意味は空 いわゆる空ですね
で 空と言った途端 実体はない
もう空しいということになりますけど
それさらに du も入れちゃう
と これ大空 小空とか 大乗仏教ですごい価値入れてますけど
そんな価値も入れてないんです
だから dukkha っていうのは
ただ 無意味 どうってことはない
気にするほどではないと
だから一切は空であるということは
一切は そんな気にするほどのものじゃない ということなんです
そんなに気にするほどですかと
そこで修行してみなさいと
そんなにも 気にするほどのことが見つかるんでしょうかと
何も見つからないはずだ
同時に 分かればわかるほど
なんか心が喜び 安らぎ
気楽になってきます
そこら辺くらいで 十分だと思いますが
今日はいっぱい 今日持ってきた情報 ひとつも言ってないんです
これからできるだけ早くして
残っている意味を説明していきます
この世の中で
私は日本語で 現象という言葉をよく使うんです 現象と
仏教の言葉は Saṅkhāra(サンカーラ)なんです
複数形で Saṅkhārā(サンカーラー)と言うんです
[Saṅkhārā]
古い仏教用語で 行という漢字を入れます
行 行くという漢字　銀行の行という漢字があります
それはもう古い日本語の訳ですけどね
でも行といってもわからないし
だから 私は現象という言葉を使っています
お釈迦様が 一切の現象は空である とおっしゃったんです
一切は空である とは言ってはいないんです
別に 一切と言ったってわからないしね
一切の現象は空であると
この現象って何でしょうかね
現象っていうのは
成り立っている すべてのものに言えるもので
ここら辺は説明どうしよう
コンディショナル (conditional) すべてもう成り立っているもの
組み立てられているものという意味なんです
例えば こちらに水入ってるペットボトルありますよ
と思っても これが現象で
なぜ現象かというと このポリエチレンのものがある
ある形にならなくちゃいけないし
中に水が入ってなきゃいけないし
これを我々は蓋というかもしれません
なぜ蓋というと ある働きをして
こちらでこうやってあるんだから
ですから組み立てたんだから
その現象が成り立つ
これをマイクロフォンというでしょ
これはなぜマイクロフォンというかというと
いろんな プラスチックの部品 金属の部品
プラスチックの部品と金属の部品が
適当に組み合わさった上で マイクロフォンと言うんです
だからマイクロフォンというのは現象です
マイクロフォンには心臓 魂
何かあるわけじゃないんです
ただ組み立てたんだから
一時的にそうなっただけ
古い経典では
車というたとえで説明するんですね
車ありますよと ありますよと
じゃあどちらが車ですか？と
車輪 軸 あるいはくびき
あるいは屋根 あるいは飾り
どちらが車ですか？と
どちらも車ではありません
例えば ABCDEFGとかね
10種類ぐらいの部品がある 車にも
一つも車ではないのに
不思議なこと 組み立てたら車があるんだよと言うんですね
そこが現象論なんですね
もともとは全くなかったんです
ただ 組み立てたら 一時的に 存在するようになっちゃうんです
逆に見ても 車の車輪は 永久的に車輪でしょうに
つなげただけで車輪が変身して 違う品物になったわけでもないでしょう
例えば この服ありますね
服と言うんだけど 結局 糸でしょ？糸は今も糸でしょう
だから 糸と服の関係は何なんでしょうかね
糸にもともと服があったんですかね
糸一本見たら あ こういう風なかっこいい服だなとかね
なかったでしょうに でも
糸をそうやってつなげてみたところ
ああ 結構 いい生地だなとかなるでしょう
そこで 服のね 縦軸の糸を我々は別々にしてもらう
それで何か消えますか？何か大事なもの落ちますか？どこかに
あ 生地が落ちちゃったんだとか 調べてみてください
何も落ちません
もし生地という実体があったならば あの糸をどんどんバラしていくと
生地が幽霊のような感じで 生地として逃げてるかもしれませんですけど
そんなこともないでしょう
ですから この現象という言葉
saṅkhārā という言葉は 仏教の命なんです
組み立ててないものは 何一つもないんです
例えば こちらに部屋がありますよ といっても
ただもうコンクリートやら いろんなものを コンクリートだから
いろいろ部品を そこら辺 それなりに組み立てただけ
それで今 すごい立派な 高価な部屋が存在しているんですけど
この建物壊れると この大事な 高価な部屋が 幽霊になって どこかに逃げていくんですかね
いられないんだから 他のところに幽霊として行きましょうと
ないでしょう そのまま消える
そこでさらに考えてみると
すべてのものは現象なんです
マイクロフォンの鉄も現象であって
プラスチックの部品も現象であって
服の場合は 糸も現象でしょ
糸もまた 別なものから出てくるものだから
例えば化学製品のね 化繊だったら単なる化学
化学物質でしょうに 粉とか液体とか
綿のものだったら ただの綿の細いあれでしょうね
だからあくまでも どこまで見ても現象
実体 見つからないんですね
現象っていうのは長持ちはしません
すぐ潰れてしまいます
だからマイクロフォンなんかは 長持ちはしません
すぐもう潰れてしまいます
シャボン玉と同じ シャボン玉もあるんだけど
あれはあの 石鹸のおかげで
水がちょっと つなげておいてつなげてしまうんですね
いわゆるこの 日本語 言葉はちょっとわかりませんけど
なんとか化学的な言葉ありますけど
surface tension (表面張力) と英語で言いますけど
このその表面的にお互いに引っ張るエネルギーが出て
その中に空気が入っちゃって
それぐらいのことで それでちょっとしたことで
温度を変えただけでも
ほんのわずかな変化でパッとはじけちゃうんです
それで大事な きれいな
美しい あのシャボン玉が どこに行ったんでしょうかとかね
どこに行ったんですかね
もともと いたわけじゃないし
はじけたところでどこに行ったわけでもない
ただの現象
だから この体もたった一つの現象
この心もたった瞬間の現象
今 楽しいと思っても
次の瞬間で 違う条件によって気持ち悪いと
それで一生気持ち悪いかというと そうでもない
他のちょっとしたことで また違う気持ち
この部屋は暖かいな 気持ちいいなと思っても
外に出たときに あー寒いよ寒いとなっちゃうでしょうに
だから 暖かい気持ちいい
寒い 気持ち悪いってことでなるでしょう
だからあなたの心はどんな調子かと
ハッキリしなさいと 私は怒っても どうにもならないでしょう
あなた この部屋の中ですごく気持ちよくいたでしょうに
なんでバス停で立ってる時はそんなに気持ち悪く立ってますかと
あなた一体どんな性格ですか？と私が怒っても意味がないでしょう
その条件 その条件で心が変わるんです
だから心も現象 体も現象
だから実体もない
だから変わっていく
どれぐらい時間持ちますか？ということは
この現象の原因によります
シャボン玉はもう一分
一秒だったら最高 一秒持てば
こういうふうな もう硬いものできている現象は
それなりに何年か持つでしょうとかね
で この体はもっと早く壊れていきますけど
やっぱり生き物だから
壊れるたびに毎日 だから一日三回召し上がっているでしょう
激しく体が壊れているんです
これもそんなに何もしなくても
かなり 10年でも持ちます
体は一日二日も持てません
壊れてガラガラと壊れちゃうんです
だからずっと もう材料を入れっぱなし
壊れるたびにこちらから補給する
だから我々は一分 何回 呼吸していますかね
考えてください 外の物質
どれぐらい入れ替えていますかと
そこで食べ物を食べて
一日三回食べて それから間食もして
もういろんなことをして
とにかくもう それに一生かかっちゃうんですね
皆様に生きる暇がないんです
壊れかけている体に 品物を補給することで精いっぱいです
いわゆる修理するは するは 終わりがない
生まれた瞬間から修理 始めるんです 人間が
それで死ぬ瞬間まで修理工場
生きている暇も余裕ないんです
だから体はすごく激しく壊れていきます
だから壊れ方のスピードっていうのは
その現象によります
花だったら 1日で枯れる場合もあるし
1週間で枯れる場合もあるし
地球はまあ何千万年も持つでしょう
でも国々はもっと短いでしょ　命は
潰れちゃうんですね
山とかは またもっと命が短い　潰れてしまう
その上で生きている我々は ものすごい もう瞬間で消えてしまう
そうやって 現象の命っていうのは 寿命と言うんですけど
それは そのものによって違いますけどね
犬の一生は 15年であって
人間の一生は 90年ぐらいでしょうしね
でも あの昆虫の一生は 1ヶ月とか 3ヶ月とか 1週間とかね
でも一つ一つは完璧な寿命そのものですけどね
それで 心さえ現象です
時々私はあ 怒ったと言うでしょ
この怒りも現象なんです
何かがなかったら生まれません
あ 楽しいと思った途端
それ 何かがなかったら 楽しくならないんです
だからそれも現象です
ああ 考えましたと言うでしょうね
それも現象です 何かなかったら考えません
そこで私がいるんだ 私には霊魂があるんだと思ってるでしょ
それ何かがあってそう思ってるだけで 現象です
故に 霊魂も現象 魂も現象
体も現象 心も現象 ことごとく全てが現象です
現象ということは 生地と糸とみたいな感じで
結局は何もないと 現象だからこそ変化する
変化するんだからこそ 実体はない
故に dukkhaと言うんです
それであの 方程式みたいな言葉がありまして
ヤンドゥッカン
[Yad aniccaṃ taṃ dukkhaṃ]
yad aniccaṃ　アニチャン aniccaṃ というのは無常ということで
で 文字通りに読めばヤダニッチャンなんですけど
学者いっぱいいるんだから もう喋りにくくなってますけどね
だから とにかくこのヤダ
yad aniccaṃ 無常なるものは
taṃ これは dukkhaṃ 苦であると
だから変化するんだということなんです 苦ということは
これ日本語どう訳すればいいんでしょうかね
無常だから苦である というふうに考えた方がやりやすいですけどね
それで納得いかない方々は
もう厳密に日本訳をしてもらった方がいいんですけど
私にはちょっとこういう言葉
日本語できませんだけど
Whatever is impermanent, it is suffering.
というふうな英訳になりますけどね
いわゆる 無常だから苦だよと
無常たるものは 苦になりますと
苦と言えますと それぐらいの単純な日本語なんです
日本語で言うと　ですから
逆に言えば お釈迦様は dukkhaと言ったのは
すべてのものは変化していくんだ という意味なんです
何でも変化するんだよと
止まってはいません それなんです
それはすごい真理なんです
だってみんな 止まっていると勘違いしてるでしょ
試しに 今 この部屋 電気ついてますか？
はい そうでしょって思ってるでしょう
変でしょ その答えは　光が止まってるわけじゃないでしょうに
ずっと変化して流れている
でも私たちは はい ここに部屋があります
ここに光があります とか
さっさと平気で 簡単に言ってしまいますが
そんなあるということじゃない
ずっと流れて 変わっていくんです
サンカーラーだから 現象だから どうせ消える
その消えることに お釈迦様は大した意味がない
そんなもうそんなに真剣に考える必要はないという意味で
dukkhaと 空しいと言うんです
ああ そう そんなのかという意味なんですよ
例えば すごいバカでかい綺麗なシャボン玉を作ったところで
えらくびっくりしたんだと
あまりにも綺麗で ただそれだけでしょ
すぐパッとはじけるんだから
シャボン玉だからどうってことはないと
すべてのものは無常だから
どうってことはない
という意味で dukkhaと言うんです
ですから 皆様方は現象論を理解するか
あるいは人生からすべての 誰が どういうふうに生きてきたといっても
ミミズと競争すれば どちらが勝つかと言えないんだと
アメリカの大統領と 自分の庭の植木鉢の下にいるミミズと
どちらが偉いとか それぐらいのものだと
生きるということは そうやって考えるか
あるいは すべては変化していくんだと無常で考えるか
無常ということはすごい大変な真理で
簡単単純な真理ではないんです
だから ものがあるということは
ものが変化するんだということで
動いているんだということで
例えば私は喋ってるでしょ
だから音あるでしょ 音はあるということは
私はずっと無常で 口から音を出していることで
出した音はその瞬間
その瞬間で消えるんです
だから音があるんです
もし音が永遠だったら
私は一言 喋ろうと思った途端
その音で永久的に音でしょう そうすると
もう喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
あまりにも音がありすぎて消えませんでしょ
そんな世界はないんだからね
そう大変なこと それだったら我々現れることは何もできません
音が出た それでずっとその音があるんです
結構うるさくはなります その時は
ですから 音が出てくる
それは消えていく 出てくるは消えてる
出てきて消えていく それで私たちは音がある
この人喋ってるか あの人歌ってる
って言うんです だから無常だから生きているんでしょうし
無常だから成り立っている
だから存在イコール無常なんです
あるイコール無常なんです
一応あるという言葉がありますね
だから そこは誰もわかってなかったんだから
永遠な話 語るでしょうし
永遠な天国とか話してるんですね
そこでお釈迦様 ああ この方々は科学者ではない
単なる無知の塊であると
永遠って成り立ちませんと
永遠イコール無常なんです
変化することなんです
だからこの 無常というものはよく理解してみてくださいと
人間の悩み苦しみは 無常に逆らうからなんです
病気になったとしても いいんじゃないんです それで
それ嫌と思うのは
私は病気になるはずではありません と思うからなんです
旦那が死んでも 奥さんが死んでも
子供がもう 二 三歳で死んじゃっても いいでしょう それで
でもなんでそれが悲しいんですかね
死ぬべきではなかったからでしょ
だから無常に逆らうんだから
すごい ものすごいきつい悲しみが生まれてきます
例えばもう八十歳のおばあちゃん死んじゃったら
ちょっと二日間は悲しいと
それで忘れちゃいますけど
でも自分の四歳の子供が死んじゃったら
二日間では忘れられませんね
なぜかというと おばあちゃんの場合は
それほどきつく 絶対死なないということはなかったんですね
いてほしい 長生きしてほしいという気持ちはありました
元気で長生きしてほしい
それなのに八十歳で消えちゃった
だから悲しかったんですね
ああ 悲しいと でも二日で忘れちゃう
だから悲しみが少ない
それで自分の四歳の子供が死んじゃった
そうすると 自分が怒れるほど悲しくなっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 死ぬはずではなかったでしょ
そんなはずっていうのはありますかね
すべて無常だから お金がなくなったら悲しいでしょ
なんでしょうかね お金がなくなるはずではなかったんです
なんで 家に帰ると 家に泥棒が入ってるんです
そうすると怯えて怖くなって
慌てて走り回ったりして
警察に行ったりするんですかね
泥棒に入られて品物を持っていったら
自分がすごく悲しむんです
あの悲しみはどこから生まれてくるかというと
泥棒が入るはずではなかったんですね
このはずが 大変な苦しみをつくる
はずってないんです
何でもありだからね 無常の世界で　家を作っても潰れるし
潰れたところで悲しかったら
その人は潰れないだろうと仮定したんですね
だから病気になったら悲しくなっちゃうと
体が痛いのは別な話で
病気になったら体が痛い
それで終わり お釈迦様の体も痛かった
お釈迦様にも でもそれ苦しかったわけじゃないんです
ただ体痛い ですから 我々は病気になったら体痛いだけではなくて
すごい苦しいんですね
それが 病気になるはずじゃないからなんです
人が死んじゃったらなぜ悲しいかというと
死ぬはずじゃないからなんです
そんなことあり得ますか？この世の中で
それほどバカな人間いるんですかね
目の前で何でも変化していくにも関わらず
よくよくも自分のことにだけ無常を否定するでしょ
人のことだったら平気で
例えば南アメリカで台風でもう400人死にましたと
ああそう それで終わるんですね
平気で ああそう そんなこと聞いてる暇がないよと言って
自分がもうジャガイモの皮を剥くんです
400人以上死んでるんだけど
自分には ジャガイモの皮を剥くこと大事でしょう
それで誰かがあなたの子供
あんな階段で 転がっちゃって怪我してるんだよ と言ったら
ジャガイモの皮を剥くどころか
もうガスも電気も消さないで
病院につれていって 家に帰ると 家が火事になってるとかありますから
なんでその時だけあれほど慌てるんですかね
やっぱり人の無常だったら どうでもいいんです
認めるの偉そうに
ああ そんなことは世の中で
台風っていうのはね 自然現象だから
そんなどうにもならないんだよと
でも悲しいでしょ あれほど人をいっぺんに
そんな人っていうのはね
いくらでも死にますからね
生まれたんだったら死ななくちゃいけないんだよと偉そうなこと言うでしょうね
ついでに言いますけど
あなたの子供 今階段で転がっちゃって怪我してるんだと
あ そう とんでもないと
もうそこに飛び上がっちゃうんです
だから見てください 我々の生き方っていうのは
無常っていうのは分かったようなふりをしているんだけど
私に対しては認めませんと
それで苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
お釈迦様は答えは簡単です
あなたも無常だよと あなたは無常だよと
それだけ それを理解すれば
もう心は清らかになって解脱を体験できます
ですから dukkhaっていうのは絶対的
すごく素晴らしい 真理なんです
それほどすごい真理がないんで
なぜ真理かというと 嘘じゃないから
誰にもこれだけは違いますよと誰にも言うことできません
それだけで真理に価値あるわけじゃないんです
皆様方はもう ものすごい科学を勉強なさってるでしょう
私みたいにぐうたら坊主でも
ただパーリ語しか勉強してない
頭悪いわけじゃないでしょうね
数学やら科学やら何でも知ってるでしょうね
それでもアイン じゃなくて
アインシュタインですね
相対性理論やら すごいことを発見しましたと
思うでしょ？アインシュタインの相対論とお釈迦様の無常論と
どちらが価値ありますかね
アインシュタインの相対性理論を勉強して 心清らかになった人が一人でもいますか？
人生の苦しみがなくなった人が 一人でもいますか？
それでもって何を獲得しているんですか？ただえらいこっちゃ それだけでしょうに
だからそれとミミズの知識と何が違いますか
ミミズは土の中で 何を食べられるかというぐらいのことを知っていて
アインシュタインは相対
光はもう ねじ曲がっちゃうんだ
だからもう違うところで見えるんだとかね
物の存在っていうのは そうやってスピードによって変わるんだとかね
だから何でしょうかね それで
だから体が外の世界いじってるだけで
心はいじってないんですね
だからアインシュタインの相対論で
たとえ幼稚園の子供二人の喧嘩さえもなくすことはできません
どんなもう原子について
もうどんな核兵器作る
どんな人にしても
そういう学問的な科学的な真理
スバルの望遠鏡から見た 宇宙の世界の知恵で
幼稚園で子供二人がやり合ってるんで
それ直せますかと 仲直りできますかね
だから役に立ちますかね そんなことで
でも子供が風船が割れちゃった
この子 こいつは割っちゃったんだよと言って
もう喧嘩するときは あのね
風船っていうのはもうこいつが割らなくても
お前もそれ割っちゃいますよと
そんなものは割れるようにできてるんだと
それぐらいわからない
よくもあなたバカではないかと
一緒に遊べと言ったら 遊んでくれるでしょ
それぐらいのことで あなた割れない風船 見たことありますかと
幼稚園の子供に聞いてみてください
そう言われたら 瞬時に子供が泣き止めるんです
喧嘩もやめるんです
だから無常ということが そうやって人生にいつでも答えを教えてくれるんです
それでこの真理を知ったんだから
お釈迦様の心から 一切の煩悩が消えてしまったんです
一切の無明は消えてしまったんです
一切の欲しがる気持ち
あれ知りたい これ知りたい これやりたい あれやりたいという
この限りない人間の この走り回ること なくなっちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様も 我々と同じく出口のない
迷路の中にいたんです
お釈迦様は 他の人 あっちこち走り回ってるでしょ バカみたいに
それはしなかったんです
とにかく出口がないんだから
途中で死ぬでしょうと
それでもう一人の人は ボケーとして寝ていたでしょうね
それを見て こいつも役に立ちません
ただボケーと寝ているだけだから
そのまま死んでしまいますよと
お釈迦様は考えたんです
出口見つけようと 走り回っても意味がない
バカみたくボケーとして寝たって意味がない
一旦この壁を登ってみようと
壁を登ってみたんです
それ出口です 出口でしょ
ですから無常を知れば
問題に 人生に答えが出てくる
で dukkhaを知れば この生きる目的は手に入るんです
そうでない限りは みんな手ぶらで 永久的に走るんです
一度も人生のゴールには達しません
だから 生きることのゴールに達するためには
dukkhaというその一言を理解する必要があるんです
で 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]